das goethe denkmal in straßburg damals
gehörte das elsass politisch schon zu
frankreich aber trotzdem sprachen hier
alle einen deutschen dialekt johann
wolfgang von goethes freundin die
pfarrerstochter regierung verstand seine
liebesgedichte heute hätte goethe es
schwerer denn in der region zwischen
rhein und vogesen können die meisten die
sprache nicht mehr
ludwig ist rapper er findet dass
zweisprachigkeit zur kultur der elsässer
gehört er und seine kumpel machen musik
gegen rechts auf elsässer deutsch mein
bruder hatte elsässisch mit einem
palästinensertuch auf dem kopf gesungen
wir wollten damit die gängigen klischees
durchbrechen
1 der klischees deutsch stehe für
rechtsradikale stammt noch aus der zeit
des zweiten weltkriegs das problem nach
hitler hitler die elsässer kastriert
weil natürlich die idee wer macht die
fähre unserem einfahrt in die wehrmacht
zwangsrekrutiert hat obwohl die
franzosen waren und dieses trauma das
haben wir nie
martin grafs familie war selbst
betroffen sein vater diente zu
kriegsbeginn in der französischen armee
zum ende des kriegs trug er die
wehrmachtsuniform 130000 elsässer wurden
eingezogen
die nazis hatten das elsass 1940
annektiert und die elsass hat zu
sogenannten volksdeutschen erklärt noch
lange nach dem krieg war die mehrheit
der zurückgekehrten soldaten zerrissen
sie wollten sie im grunde genommen ihrer
mutter ihre frau erklären was sie
gesehen haben und vielleicht auch was
sie gemacht haben ja in russland das war
unmöglich also vorhang runter und um nie
wieder in die situation zu geraten als
franzose in eine deutsche und deutsche
uniform gegen ein anderes land zu
kämpfen haben sie sich selber die zunge
abgeschnitten in ihren kindern die zunge
abgeschnitten hat die zentralregierung
in paris verbot über jahrzehnte elsässer
deutsch an den schulen radikal mit dem
ergebnis dass selbst in den familien
immer weniger deutsch gesprochen
eine chance auf einen arbeitsplatz haben
sich viele damit verbaut blut fröhlicher
erleidet eine deutsch-französische
unternehmensberatung in colmar
innovative firmen die die nähe zum
elsass als standortvorteil betrachteten
fanden wider erwarten keine
zweisprachigen mitarbeiter da gibt es
zehntausende arbeitsplätze im deutschen
oder schweizerischen grenzgebiet aber
auch im elsass selbst die unternehmen
wollen dass die leute deutsch sprechen
und zwar mit einem hohen niveau
die französischen bewerber können die
posten nicht mehr annehmen
einfach weil ihr deutsch zu schlecht ist
deshalb schickt fröhlicher seine kinder
in eine zweisprachige schule
der deutsche mit pickelhaube oder als
dreister tour ist der vater erklärt den
kindern die karikaturen aus dem
vergangenen jahrhundert
es gibt eine kluft im elsass auf der
einen seite die leute wie wir die keine
vorurteile mehr haben die sich nur sagen
es ist gut wenn man in unserer gegend
deutsch und französisch spricht und
andere die immer noch vorurteile gegen
deutsche haben
auf druck vieler eltern hat sich
inzwischen auch die zentralregierung in
paris bewegt an etlichen schulen und
sogar schon in den kindergärten gibt es
intensiven deutschunterricht für mehr
als 25.000 kinder
würde der ansturm größer bekäme die
schulbehörde ein problem
je mehr krise wir finden nicht
ausreichend lehrer die gut genug deutsch
sprechen die also deutsch studiert haben
und es richtig sprechen
das liegt vielleicht auch daran dass wir
eine zeit lang das deutsche fallen
gelassen haben
deshalb sind jetzt an einem tiefpunkt
angelangt an dem sich immer weniger
studenten für deutsch interessieren
für den rapper nazar ludwig kommen die
zweisprachigen klassen zu spät er lernt
deutsch beim vater früher wollten meine
jungs kein deutsch lernen
damals fanden sie das hässlich aber
jetzt fragen sie wie heißt dieses oder
jenes ich spreche jetzt auch mit meinen
enkeln elsässer deutsch
ich will dass meine muttersprache auch
weiter gesprochen wird
für den alten goethe besteht also doch
ein hoffnungsschimmer dass bald wieder
mehr elsässer deutsch können und er
nicht mehr so allein in straßburg steht